des lance-roquettes américain des fusils
mitrailleurs un étalage sans précédent
d'armement militaire
c'est incontestablement une
démonstration de force
le nombre des militants 5 à 6 ans
rassemblé clandestinement dans le maquis
visa impressionné c'est l'une des
conférences de presse les plus
importantes jamais organisées par le
flnc
elle est signée canal historique la
branche qui a revendiqué les récents
attentats commis en corse les attentats
qui ont fait 200 millions de francs de
dégâts
à quelques heures de l'arrivée encore
d'un ministre de l'intérieur ce
déploiement de force n'est pas innocent
cette nuit pourtant le flnc a voulu
annoncer un signe d'apaisement la trêve
des attentats
celle ci se traduira dans un premier
temps par une suspension de toutes ses
opérations militaires pour une durée de
trois mois à présent tel déploiement de
force à présent tel silence des
autorités
difficile lorsqu'on est un simple
citoyen de corse de croire encore en
l'autorité de l'état
un lieu qui sont deux attentats ont une
âme et vous n'avez rien fait mais on va
essayer de leur échelle humaine
on va faire évoluer la loi on note dans
les salons de la préfecture d'ajaccio
l'ambiance était ce soir toute
différente ici on est entre soi entre
membres du clan c'est donc à ses
représentants de la place politique
corse traditionnels que jean louis debré
a décidé de réserver la primeur de ses
réflexions
son premier souci rassurer les élus
l'état demeurera encore comme la corse
restera dans la france son second souci
expliqué qu'il est peut-être temps
dehors des concessions oui mesdames et
messieurs j'ai le sentiment profond
qu'aujourd'hui c'est peut-être ouvert
même s'il est fragile
l'espace nécessaire à la discussion et
au dialogue
le ministre de l'intérieur entamera dès
demain ce dialogue en allant rencontrer
les représentants nationaliste à
l'assemblée de corse où là